.
SE B UEI RE OR
DAE AOIINMAHA L TL 30STEPIS T TM
BREANG THE ALL-TIME RECORD.
AND WE GOT A STEPH BOOST FOR
YOU.
A STEPH THREE BY TWO AND A SAME
GAME PARLAY LIFT.
HOW MANY THREES DO YOU THINK
STEPH WILL HAVE BY THE TIME HE
RETIRES?
THAT IS A TOUGH QUESTION.
HE IS PLAYING LIKE HE WILL STICK
AROUND FOR A LONG TIME.
IF HE CONTINUES ON THAT PATH HE
IS ON NOW, THE NUMBER WILL SCARE
MOST OF US.
HE IS DEFINITELY ON FIRE FROM
THREE.
TIME WILL TELL.
IT WILL BE A BIG ONE FOR SURE.
>> IT WILL BE A BIG ONE.
THAT WAS A TOUGH QUESTION.
BUT AS ALWAYS WE ARE GIVING AWAY
LOCKS AND HOODIES AND GIVING
AWAY JERSEYS.
BUT TODAY WE ARE ALSO GIVINGA,
WAY, LIV, AN IPHONE 13 AFTER THE
GAME TO ONE LUCKY COMMENTER.
GET IN THE COMMENTS.
GET IN THE COMMENTS YOU GUYS
KNOW WHAT I NEED.
I NEED GIFS AND EMOJIS AND YOU
GUYS KNOW I NEED WINNERS ONLY.
PLEASE.
BUT I SPECIFICALLY WANT TO SEE
STEPH GIFS TODAY.
I WANT TO SEE STEPH GIFS IN THE
COMMENTS.
IT IS CHRISTMAS SEASON.
WHY NOT GIVE AWAY A JERSEY RIGHT
NOW.
I WILL GIVE AWAY HOODIES.
SAVE THE JERSEYS FOR LATER.
I HAVE JOE FABIO SAYING STEPH
WILL BREAK THE RECORD 3:20 INTO
THE FIRST QUARTER.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
WE ASKED ALL FANS IN THE APP TO
TELL US WHAT THE EXACT TIME YOU
THINK THAT STEPH WILL BREAK THE
RECORD TONIGHT.
I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS FOR A CHANCE TO WIN AN
IPHONE 13.
THAT IS THE END OF THE GAME.
ONE WINNER AND HOOK YOU UP.
LIV, DO YOU HAVE AN IPHONE 13
YET?
>> I DON'T.
I FEEL LIKE I NEED TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS NOW.
>> HOP ON IN.
HOP ON IN.
I AM GO TO LOOK FOR YOU IN THE
COMMENTS.
I DON'T EVEN HAVE A IPHONE 13.
I WANT TO HOP IN THE COMMENTS.
AM I ELIGIBLE TOO?
SERIOUSLY.
BUT IN HONOR OF STEPH, POTENTIAL
RECORD-BREAKING NIGHT, FANDUEL.
FANDUEL IS GIVING US THE BR
SUPER BOOST ON A SPECIAL STEPH
PROP TODAY.
THE QUESTION IS WILL STEPH HIT
TWO OR MORE THREE-POINTERS AND
BREAK THE RECORD IN THE FIRST
QUARTER, LIV?
FANDUEL IS BOOSTING THE ODDS
FROM MINUS 110 TO PLUS 150.
LIV, DO YOU LIKE THE PLUS MONEY
ON THIS?
>> I DO.
I ALWAYS LOVE PLUS MONEY.
I WILL ALWAYS TAKE PLUS MONEY IF
I THINK IT IS A GOOD PLAY AND I
DO THINK THIS IS A GOOD PLAY.
STEPH IS OBVIOUSLY GOING FOR A
RECORD BREAKING NIGHT.
HE IS TRYING TO MAKE HISTORY.
I LOVE THE PLAY.
NOT ONLY THAT, I KNOW THERE ARE
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO ARE A
LITTLE BIT NERVOUS ABOUT THE
BACK-TO-BACK MATCHUP FOR THE
WARRIORS TEAM.
I KNOW THEY WERE STUCK IN
INDIANA LAST NIGHT.
THEY WERE HAVING MECHANICAL
ISSUES WITH THEIR PLANES.
THAT WAS SOMETHING I THOUGHT
ABOUT THIS MORNING.
I AM KIND OF NERVOUS TO RIDE
WITH THIS WARRIORS TEAM TODAY.
BUT AFTER DOING SOME RESEARCH, I
REALIZED STEPH CURRY THRIVES ON
ZERO DAYS REST.
HE ABSOLUTELY THRIVES.
EARLIER IN THE SEASON HE HAD 50
POINTS AND NINE THREES ON NO
REST AGAINST THE HAWKS.
AND IN A SEPARATE GAME HE HAD 27
POINTS AND 5 THREES ON NO REST
AGAINST THE SPURS.
IT SEEMS LIKE NO REST DOES
WONDERS FOR STEPH CURRY, AND YOU
ADD IN THE FACT HE IS TRYING TO
MAKE HISTORY TONIGHT.
I THINK HE GETS HOT IMMEDIATELY
COMING OUT OF THE GATES IN THE
FIRST QUARTER.
I DO LOVE THE PLAY.
I DO LOVE IT IS PLUS MONEY.
>> I LOVE IT TOO.
I LOVE IT TOO.
YOU MENTIONED STEPH, YOU
MENTIONED HIM BREAKING THE
RECORD TONIGHT.
YOU MENTIONED HIM MAKING
THREE-POINTERS TONIGHT.
LIV, I WANT TO TELL THE PEOPLE A
VERY IMPORTANT FACT.
STEPH LOVES PLAYING AT MADISON
SQUARE GARDEN.
HE LOVES TO PLAY THERE.
I SEE HIM GETTING THIS RECORD
EARLY AND PUTTING ON A SHOW FOR
THE PEOPLE AT THE GARDEN.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
I AM GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND A
JERSEY HERE, LIV.
LET ME SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
THIS IS THE HANDY DANDY IPAD.
THIS IS HOW YOU GET YOUR
HOODIES.
HERE WE GO.
CURRY MAKES HISTORY TONIGHT,
YES, SIR.
WE KNOW CURRY IS GOING TO MAKE
HISTORY TONIGHT.
JUST BECAUSE YOU COMMENTED YOU
ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
ALSO, I GOT WINNERS ONLY.
WINNERS ONLY, HE IS GOING TO DO
IT WITH 2:56 LEFT IN THE SECOND
QUARTER.
WOW.
2:56 LEFT IN THE SECOND QUARTER.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
XKCX, THIS IS THE JERSEY WINNER
RIGHT HERE.
SHE IS AS STEPH GOT THIS, SECOND
QUARTER, 7:00, 14 LEFT ON THE
CLOCK.
THAT IS WHEN STEPH WILL KNOCK IT
DOWN.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE.
LIV, TNT TUESDAY.
THAT MEANS WE GOT MORE ODDS
BOOSTS FOR YOU.
FANDUEL IS BOOSTING THE THREE BY
TWO IN BOTH GAMES TONIGHT.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS, LIV.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CALLING IT.
THREE BY TUESDAY, THE QUESTION
IS WILL THERE BE TWO
THREE-POINTERS IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES OF THE GAME.
TODAY WE ASKED YOU ON TWITTER
WHICH THREE BY TWO WILL CASH,
THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS TAKING
ON THE KNICKS OR THE PHOENIX
SUNS TAKING ON THE PORTLAND
TRAIL BLAZERS?
HERE ARE THE CURRENT RESULTS.
OKAY.
LIV, WE HAVE THE STEPH CURRY
EFFECT GOING ON.
LIV, THERE ARE SHOOTERS IN THAT
SECOND GAME.
WE GOT PHOENIX TAKING ON
PORTLAND.
THERE ARE SHOOTERS IN THAT
SECOND GAME.
WHICH ONE DO YOU LIKE THE BEST?
>> YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THERE ARE SHOOTERS IN THE GAME
AS WELL.
FROM A DEFENSIVE PERSPECTIVE THE
TRAIL BLAZERS CURRENTLY ALLOW
THE FIFTH MOST THREES TO THE
OPPONENT AND DEFEND THE
THREE-POINT LINE THE WORST IN
THE LEAGUE.
THEY ALLOW THEIR OPPONENTS THE
HIGHEST THREE-POINT PERCENTAGE
IN THE LEAGUE RIGHT NOW.
YOU TAKE INTO THE ACCOUNT YOU
HAVE SHOOTERS AND POOR PERIMETER
DEFENSE, I THINK THE
PORTLAND/PHOENIX GAME IS WORTH A
LITTLE BIT OF A SPRINKLE.
BUT I HAVE TO RIDE WITH THE
WARRIORS.
STEPH IS TRYING TO MAKE HISTORY.
THIS IS A WARRIORS TEAM THAT
RANKS SECOND FOR THREE-POINTERS
MADE AND A KNICKS TEAM RANKING
SIXTH.
I THINK IT WILL BE A THREE-POINT
SHOOTOUT.
I THINK STEPH CURRY GETS HOT
EARLY BECAUSE HE IS TRYING TO
MAKE HISTORY AND CONTINUES TO
SHOOT FROM THE THREE-POINT LINE
THE ENTIRETY OF THE GAME.
I GOT TO RIDE WITH THE WARRIORS
AND THE KNICKS IN THE THREE BY
TWO, BUT I THINK THE OTHER ONE
IS WORTH ESPECIALLY WHEN IT IS
PLUS MONEY.
>> I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE IT A LOT.
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS TAKING ON
THE KNICKS.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
GO GARDEN SAYS SUNS ARE GETTING
BOTH.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU GO GARDEN.
YES, THERE WILL BE TWO BY CURRY.
CURRY CASHING IT ALL FOR US.
I AM GOING TO MAKE A DECISION
HERE, LIV.
WE ARE ALL RIDING.
IT IS STEPH'S NIGHT.
STEPH IS AT THE GARDEN.
WE ARE RIDING THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS TAKING ON THE NEW YORK
KNICKS, THREE BY TWO.
WE NEEDED TO SEE TWO OF THOSE GO
IN IN THE FIRST THREE MINUTES.
WE ARE NOT ONLY RIDING THAT ONE.
LET'S SPRINKLE IT ON THE LATER
GAME.
LET'S ALL GET RICH.
LAST WEEK, LIV, I DIDN'T HIT BUT
A LOT OF PEOPLE HIT ON THE ALL
NEW YORK TEAM PARLAY.
LIV, DID YOU RIDE THE BING-BONG
PARLAY?
>> I DIDN'T AND I WISH I HAD.
EVERYONE WAS CASHING OUT ON THE
BING-BONG PARLAY.
WE HAD A PRETTY SOLID WEEK.
THREE BY TWO, BIG BONG PARLAY.
A HOT AND FIERY WEEK.
WE WERE ALL CASHING OUT.
>> LIV, YOU MISSED IT BUT THEY
ARE RUNNING IT BACK TONIGHT.
I GREG IVORY ARE TELLING YOU
GUYS TO NOT TAKE THE BING BONG
PARLAY.
KNICKS AND THE NETS ARE PLAYING
TONIGHT.
IF YOU ARE BETTING THE
BASKETBALL BING BONG PARLAY,
TELL US WHAT YOU THINK.
ODDS ARE PLUS 298 FOR A
KNICKS-NETS MONEYLINE PARLAY.
LIV, I DON'T LIKE IT AT ALL AND
YOU KNOW WHY I DON'T LIKE IT AND
THE PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS KNOW
WHY I DON'T LIKE IT.
TALK TO THEM.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
DO YOU LIKE THIS BING BONG
PARLAY?
>> YOU KNOW, I DON'T HATE IT.
BUT THE ONLY REASON THAT I COULD
SEE IT HITTING IS BECAUSE OF
WHERE THE PUBLIC MONEY IS RIGHT
NOW IN THE TWO GAMES.
NEARLY 70% OF PUBLIC MONEY IS
RIDING WITH THE WARRIORS AND
OVER 70% OF THE PUBLIC IS RIDING
WITH THE RAPTORS.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS A MILLION
TIMES.
IT IS NEVER A HORRIBLE IDEA.
NOW, OBVIOUSLY I THINK THE NETS
HAVE A MUCH BETTER CHANCE UP
AGAINST THE RAPTORS THAN I THINK
THAT THE KNICKS DO AGAINST THE
WARRIORS.
I THINK THE WARRIORS ARE WINNING
TONIGHT.
I THINK IT IS ALL ABOUT STEPH
CURRY.
I DON'T THINK THE KNICKS TEAM
WILL PULL OFF AN UPSET TONIGHT.
HOWEVER I COULD SEE THE PART OF
THIS BING BONG PARLAY HITTING IS
THE NETS.
I FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
BET.
I AM NOT SO SURE THAT I TRUST
THE KNICKS TO DEFEAT A WARRIORS
TEAM WITH SO MUCH RIDING ON IT
TONIGHT AND A HOT STEPH CURRY TO
ME IS UNSTOPPABLE.
I CAN SEE IT FOR THE SAKE OF THE
PUBLIC BUT I DON'T LOVE THE
KNICKS PLAY.
I AM NOT BIAS AND DON'T HAVE A
HUGE LOVE FOR THE WARRIORS.
SIMPLY COMING FROM THE FACT I
THINK THE WARRIORS ARE THE
BETTER TEAM.
MAYBE A SPRINKLE BUT I DON'T
LOVE IT BECAUSE I AM ROOTING FOR
THE WARRIORS.
>> YOU BROUGHT ALL OF YOUR
STATISTICS, TODAY.
TALKING ABOUT THE WARRIORS ON
BACK-TO-BACK NIGHTS AND ALL DAY.
I DON'T LIKE IT.
OBVIOUSLY YOU GUYS KNOW.
I AM RIDING WITH THE BING BING
PARLAY.
LET ME SEE IF YOU WILL ROCK IT
WITH ME IN THE BING BING.
BING-BING, HE IS RIDING THE
BING-BING PARLAY.
RITCHIE 21 SAYS GOT IT LAST WEEK
BUT TODAY IT ISN'T HITTING.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY I
MENTIONED.
YOU ARE ALL WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LET'S TALK MAJOR MARKETS
MONEYLINES AGAINST THE SPREAD
AND POINT TOTALS FOR TONIGHT.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING HERE?
WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
>> LOVING OVER 211 IN THE
WARRIORS/KNICKS GAME.
I THINK THIS IS A THREE-POINT
SHOOTOUT BETWEEN THE TWO TEAMS.
TWO TEAMS RANKED IN THE TOP OF
THREE-POINTERS MADE, AND THE
WARRIORS ON NO REST ARE 2-0-1
WITH THE OVER.
THEY HAVE HIT THE OVER 100% OF
THE TIME ON NO REST, AND THIS
KNICKS' TEAM WHO IS ON TWO TO
THREE DAYS REST HAVE HIT THE
OVER THREE.
THE WARRIORS HIT THE OVER 100%
OF THE TIME ON NO DAYS REST AND
THAT IS EXACTLY THE CIRCUMSTANCE
WE ARE BEING LOOING AT TONIGHT.
ONE TEAM NO REST AND THE OTHER
TWO TO THREE DAYS.
TWO TEAMS KNOWING HOW TO SHOOT
WELL FROM THE THREE.
THAT IS MY BEST BET FOR TONIGHT.
>> LIV IS ROCKING WITH THE OVER.
I AM GOING TO KEEP IT REALLY
SIMPLE WITH YOU GUYS.
I HAVE A PARLAY OUT RIGHT NOW.
I AM GOING TO DROP THE WARRIORS'
MONEYLINE.
GREG, MINUS 210.
THAT IS A LOT OF JUICE.
NO.
GO AND RIDE THE BING BING
PARLAY, JUST A LEG OF THE
PARLAY.
RIDING WITH THE WARRIORS.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
I AM GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
STEPH IS GOING FOR 35, SEVEN
THREES TONIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT GEORGE SAYING JAKE REALLY
GOING FOR HIS PRIZE.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
GEORGE.
YOU KNOW I GUESS I WILL GIVE YOU
A HOODIE.
>> YOU ARE ALL WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
NOW IT IS TIME FOR LOCK OR NOT.
I AM GOING TO PUT UP A PROP.
I NEED ALL OF YOU IN THE
AUDIENCE TO GET IN THE COMMENTS
AND TELL ME IF IT IS A LOCK OR
NOT.
THAT IS ALL I NEED, LOCK OR NOT.
LOCK OR NOT.
THERE IT IS.
ARE YOU READY?
>> I AM READY.
>> LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
FIRST UP IS CHRIS PAUL TO RECORD
A DOUBLE-DOUBLE AGAINST THE
BLAZERS.
IT IS SITTING AT MINUS 110, LIV.
DO YOU LIKE THIS?
IS THIS A LOCK?
IS IT NOT?
>> I DO LIKE IT AND I THINK WITH
DEVIN BOOKER OUT, CHRIS PAUL IS
STEPPING UP INTO A MORE
LEADERSHIP TYPE OF A ROLE WHERE
HE IS NOT JUST FOCUSING ON ONE
THING OR ANOTHER.
HE IS DOING A LITTLE BIT OF
BUFFET STYLE BASKETBALL.
HE HAS TO DO A LITTLE BIT OF
EVERYTHING.
HE IS THE LEADER AND THE VETERAN
ON THE TEAM.
BOOKER BEING OUT.
CHRIS PAUL HAS TO STEP UP TO DO
A LOT OF FACILITATING, EVEN
REBOUNDING, ASSISTS, POINTS.
I LIKE IT FOR HIM.
IN THE LAST THREE GAMES HE HIT
IT IN TWO OF THE LAST THREE.
THE LAST GAME IT SEEMS LIKE HE
IT WAS OFF.
BUT IT WAS UP AGAINST THE
CLIPPERS.
MAYBE HE WASN'T ALL THE WAY
DIALED UP IN.
I LIKE IT TONIGHT AGAINST A
TRAIL BLAZERS' TEAM THAT DOES
NOT NECESSARILY HAVE THE
STRONGEST DEFENSE IN TERMS OF
THE POINTS AND REBOUNDS ALLOWED
AS WELL AS ASSISTS ALLOWED.
BECAUSE OF THE WEAKER DEFENSE, I
LIKE CHRIS PAUL TO BE ABLE TO
GET THE DOUBLE-DOUBLE.
I LIKE IT.
I AM STAYING IN THE LOCK.
>> I AM FOLLOWING YOU, LIV.
WE KNOW WHAT CHRIS PAUL LIKES TO
DO.
HE LOVES TO DISH THE ROCK.
HE ALSO IS CHRIS PAUL.
HE IS A SCORER.
I SEE HIM GETTING THE
DOUBLE-DOUBLE.
I SEE HIM GETTING IT IN THE GAME
AGAINST THE PORTLAND TRAIL
BLAZERS.
LET ME SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
EASY LOCK, LIV.
DENG G-- DAME GOING TO COME OUT
TO PLAY.
CHRIS PAUL DOUBLE-DOUBLE IS A
LOCK.
I GOT ONE MORE.
I GOT ONE MORE IN ME.
EASY LOCK, GREG.
EASY LOCK.
DOUBLE-DOUBLE FOR CHRIS PAUL.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYONE I
MENTIONED.
NEXT UP IS DAMIAN LILLARD.
TOP SCORER TONIGHT.
TOP SCORER SITTING AT MINUS 150.
DO YOU LIKE THIS?
DO YOU NOT?
IS IT A LOCK OR IS IT NOT?
>> I THINK THAT IT IS A LOCK.
I REALLY DO.
I THINK THAT HE IS AM COMING
BACK.
HE IS GETTING BACK IN HEALTH.
HE IS GETTING BACK ON THE COURT.
THIS IS A DAMIAN LILLARD THAT
KNOWS HOW TO SHOOT THE BALL.
HE KNOWS HOW TO SCORE.
THAT IS SOMETHING I NEVER HAD TO
WORRY ABOUT HIM, EVER.
HE IS GOING UP AGAINST A SUNS'
TEAM THAT KIND OF DISTRIBUTES
THEIR POINTS THROUGHOUT THE
MAJORITY OF THE STARTERS.
THERE IS NOT ONE GUY, IF THERE
IS ONE GUY DOING A MAJORITY OF
THE SCORING IT IS BOOKER.
I DO LIKE DAMIAN LILLARD TO BE
THE GUY TONIGHT.
LIKE I SAID HE IS COMING BACK.
I ALSO HAVE SEEN A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT DAMIAN
LILLARD POTENTIALLY TALKING
ABOUT WANTING TO PLAY OTHER
PLACES.
THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE HE WANTS TO GO.
I DO LIKE THE PLAY WITH DEVIN
BOOKER OUT.
I AM GOING TO TAKE IT.
DAMIAN LILLARD AS THE TOP SCORER
TONIGHT COMING BACK.
I LIKE IT.
I AM TAKING IT.
IT IS A LOCK.
>> I LIKE THE WAY THAT YOU
THINK.
BUT I DO NOT KNOW IF I LOVE IT
ON THIS ONE.
I AM GOING TO GO THE OTHER WAY.
DAME IS COMING BACK FROM AN
INJURY.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE IS GOING TO
GO THROUGH THE MOTIONS AND GET
HIS LEGS RIGHT THIS GAME.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WILL BE A
CONDITIONING GAME FOR DAME.
TO LAY MINUS 150.
I DON'T KNOW IF I AM GOING TO
LAY MY MONEY ON THAT WITH ALL OF
THE QUESTIONS SURROUNDING DAME'S
HEALTH.
I AM GO TO LEAN THE OTHER WAY.
IT IS NOT ABOUT ME BUT THE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS.
DAME, BUCKET, BUCKET.
DAME IS A BUCKET.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
FINALLY NURKIC TO GRAB 12 OR
MORE REBOUNDS.
IT IS SITTING AT PLUS 146.
TALK TO ME LIV.
IS IT A LOCK OR IS IT NOT?
>> NO.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I CAN'T DO IT TO MYSELF AGAIN.
I LOST WAY TOO MUCH MONEY ON
NURKIC.
HE GETS THE BOARDS.
YOU GO TO BET ON HIM.
I REFUSE TO LAY MY MONEY ON
NURKIC AGAIN.
HE IS GOING UP AGAINST A SUNS
TEAM WITH DEANDRE AYTON.
THAT MATCHUP I DON'T LOVE FOR
NURKIC.
I THINK HE PLAYS TOO TIMID.
I DON'T LOVE THIS MATCHUP FOR
HIM CONSIDERING HE IS GOING UP
AGAINST A BIG GUY LIKE AYTON.
IT IS A NO.
IT MAKES ME FEEL EVEN MORE LIKE
IT IS NOT A LOCK.
I MIGHT BE DOING A LITTLE
BETTING WITH MY HEART.
I HAVE BEEN BURNED BY NURKIC.
I AM NOT DOING IT AGAIN.
SAYING IT IS NOT A LOCK.
>> YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO DO.
I AM GOING TO TALK ABOUT THIS
PICK.
NURKIC.
HE IS NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO
WHAT HE WANTS TO DO.
I DON'T THINK HE WILL BE ABLE TO
GRAB 12 REBOUNDS.
I WILL TELL YOU WHY.
CHRIS PAUL, DEANDRE AYTON, THEY
LIKE TO RUN THE PICK-AND-ROLL UP
TOP.
USUALLY THAT MEANS NURKIC IS
GOING TO SWITCH ON TO CHRIS
PAUL.
HE IS GOING TO BE TOWARDS THE
PERIMETER, UP TOWARDS THE
PERIMETER.
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO GRAB 12
REBOUNDS WITH THAT PHILOSOPHY.
IT IS NOT GOING TO WORK.
ALSO, YOU MENTIONED DEANDRE
AYTON.
I WILL TAKE NURKIC OVER DEANDRE
AYTON IN THE REBOUNDING
COMPETITION ANY DAY.
I DO NOT LIKE THIS.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW
LIV GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
MG300 SAYS AYTON NOT PLAYING.
I THINK EASY LOCK FOR SURE.
THEY ARE RIDING, LIV.
I GOT ONE MORE.
ONE MORE.
TY17 SAYS THIS IS NOT A LOCK.
NOT A LOCK.
LET'S MOVE ON.
TIME TO BUILD THE BR BETTING
CUSTOM PARLAY.
YOU GUYS AT HOME CAN ACTUALLY
RIDE WITH US ON FANDUEL.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT HAPPENED LAST
WEEK, LIV.
TELL THEM WHAT HAPPENED LAST
WEEK.
>> WE CASHED, BABY.
WE CASHED ON THE THREE BY TWO.
IT WAS A GREAT NIGHT.
GREAT NIGHT.
>> YES.
TONIGHT ON THE INSIDE THE NBA
PREGAME SHOW CHUCK WILL LOOK AT
OUR PARLAY AND PICK HIS
FAVORITE.
I GIVE OUT THE PARLAY, I NEED
EVERYBODY TO GET IN THE KMINT
S
AND TELL ME WHAT Y'ALL THINGS.
TELL ME WHICH LEGS IS Y'ALL
GOING TO TAKE.
THIS WEEK WE ARE BUILDING A
STEPH GAME PARLAY.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
THE FIRST LEG.
THE FIRST LEG OF THE PARLAY IS
MY GUY, STEPH CURRY, MAKING FIVE
THREES, LIV.
HE DID IT LAST NIGHT.
DO YOU THINK HE CAN DO IT AGAIN?
>> YEAH.
I SURE DO.
HE IS LOOKING TO MAKE HISTORY.
HE PLAYS VERY WELL AT MSG.
IT IS A BIG NIGHT FOR HIM
TONIGHT.
IT IS A BIG, BIG NIGHT.
I SAW ALL OF THE POSTS ABOUT
EVERYBODY COMING OUT TO MSG TO
WATCH HIM PLAY AND TO WATCH HIM
MAKING HISTORY.
I THINK EVERYBODY KNOWS IT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
FIVE PLUS, I LOVE IT.
>> LIV LOVES IT.
OKAY.
I AM FEELING GOOD ABOUT THIS.
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT ONE.
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT LEG.
HERE WE GO.
30 PLUS POINTS, DO YOU THINK HE
CAN DO IT?
>> YES.
I DO.
ALL OF THE VARIABLES CONSIDERED
IN THE SITUATION.
MSG, TRYING TO BREAK HISTORY.
TRYING TO BREAK RECORDS.
WE LOVE IT.
ON NO DAYS REST HE IS AVERAGING
38.5 POINTS.
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE OTHER
FACTORS AND VARIABLES.
30 PLUS I THINK IS EASY MONEY
FOR HIM.
I CAN SEE HIM GOING IN TO
HALFTIME WITH 16 OR 17 POINTS.
YES.
I LOVE THE PLAY.
>> OKAY.
WE GOT THE TWO STEPH CURRY LEGS
OF THE PARLAY.
NOW THIS IS INTERESTING.
LET'S GO DRAYMOND GREEN SIX PLUS
ASSISTS, LIV.
TO ME THIS SEEMS LIKE IT.
WE KNOW HE WILL BE FEEDING STEPH
THE ROCK ALL GAME.
TALK TO ME.
DO YOU LIKE THIS?
>> I DO.
I MEAN DRAYMOND GREEN STRIKES ME
AS THE GUY/TEAMMATE THAT WANTS
TO BE A PART OF THE MOMENT WITH
STEPH AND CONTRIBUTE TO THE
HISTORIC NIGHT FOR STEPH CURRY.
THEY ARE A DYNAMIC DUO.
A PICTURE OF THEM HIGH FIVING ON
TWITTER AND EVERYBODY KEPT
SAYING THEY ARE GOING TO DO IT
AGAIN TONIGHT.
DRAYMOND WANTS TO BE AS MUCH OF
A PART OF THIS SPECIAL NIGHT HE
CAN.
HE CAN FEED STEPH THE BALL.
I THINK THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT HE
WILL DO SO STEPH MAKES HISTORY
AND HE HITS SIX PLUS AND WE CAN
CASH THE SAME GAME PARLAY.
>> LET'S GO.
LET'S GO.
LIV, WE TALK YOUR PLAY AND PUT
IT IN THE PARLAY.
YOU MENTIONED THE OVER EARLIER
IN THE SHOW.
I KNOW YOU HAVE TO LIKE IT.
YOU MENTIONED IT.
>> I LOVE IT.
I THINK IT IS A SHOOTOUT.
BOTH TEAMS GET HOT FROM THE
THREE.
I THINK IT IS A HIGH SCORING
AFFAIR.
I THINK IT GOES HAND IN HAND
WITH THE REST OF THE BETS THAT
WE GOT IN THE SAME GAME PARLAY.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO TAKE AN
UNDER AND HAVE STEPH CURRY GOING
OFF.
WE HAVE STEPH CURRY GOING OFF
AND WE LIKE THE OVER.
IT'S PERFECT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY, LIV.
LET'S PUT THE TICKET UP AND SHOW
PEOPLE HOW MUCH MONEY THEY GOING
TO GET IF THEY PLACED THIS AT
THE CASINO WITH FANDUEL.
YOU GUYS, IF Y'ALL DROP 100 YOU
ARE WALKING AWAY WITH 500 AND
CHANGE.
THERE IT IS.
LIV, BEFORE I GET INTO THE
COMMENTS, LAST WEEK YOU GAVE US
A BEAT AND WE HIT.
>> BECAUSE I HAVE SO MUCH FAITH
IN STEPH CURRY I WANT TO BUMP IT
UP TO AN A BUT MAYBE KEEP IT AT
A B IN CASE THE B HAS EXTRA GOOD
VIBES TO IT.
WE WILL ROCK WITH A B AND I
THINK STEPH CURRY HAS GOT
HIMSELF A NIGHT.
I HAVE A LOT OF FAITH IN HIM.
WE WILL GO WITH B.
THAT IS WHAT WE HAD LAST WEEK
AND WE CASHED.
GOING TO KEEP THE GOOD VIBES
ROLLING.
>> WE ARE KEEPING THE GOOD VIBES
ROLLING HERE.
B HAS GIVEN US A B.
I AM TAKING THAT.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS GIVING AWAY
HOODIES AND A JERSEY.
EASY MONEY PARLAY.
BEEN MANIFESTING THE HOODIE ALL
WEEK.
GREG GOT THE SAME LEG AS ME FOR
THE PARLAY.
DREAM MEANT TO COME TRUE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
I LOVE THAT.
GIVING AWAY ONE MORE HOODIE.
RC ITALY WITH THE WHOLE THING
BING BING.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LIV, LET'S TALK FUTURES.
STEPH CURRY THE FAVORITE TO WIN
MVP.
BEEN TELLING YOU THAT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
SINCE THE BEGINNING.
SINCE THE FIRST SHOW.
WHAT I NEED YOU TO DO RIGHT NOW
IS GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL
ME IF STEPH SHOULD WIN MVP AND
IF NOT TELL ME WHO YOU THINK
SHOULD.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE LATEST
ODDS, PLUS 145.
LIV, WHAT ARE YOUR FAVORITE BETS
ON THE BOARD?
>> I THINK STEPH CURRY IS THE
FAVORITE.
HE IS DOING STEPH CURRY THINGS.
NO OTHER WAY TO DESCRIBE IT IT.
I THINK KEVIN DURANT IS A PRETTY
CLOSE SECOND RIGHT NOW WITH WHAT
HE IS DOING WITH THE NEXT TEAM
BEING ARGUABLY THE BEST SCORER
IN THE LEAGUE.
HE CREATES OPPORTUNITIES TO GET
THE BALL IN THE BASKET AND IT IS
PRETTY IMPRESSIVE TO WATCH.
ANY TIME I AM ON THE COURT I AM
BLOWN AWAY EVERY TIME.
HIM AND STEPH BOTH I THINK ARE
CLOSE WITH EACH OTHER IN TERNMS
OF THE MVP SPOT.
I SPRINKLED A LITTLE ON JA
MORANT.
PLUS 3200.
HIM BEING INJURED IS A HUGE BLOW
TO MY BET.
HOWEVER HE WAS ADDING A LOT OF
VALUE TO THE GRIZZLIES' TEAM.
I FEEL THE SAME WAY ABOUT PAUL
GEORGE AT PLUS 5,000.
I DON'T THINK YOU GO AND PUT
YOUR COLLEGE MONEY OR RENT ON
THE PLAY.
BUT I THINK THIS IS WORTH A
SPRINKLE.
WE ARE SEEING WHAT HE IS DOING
WITH THE CLIPPERS TEAM.
HE IS THAT GUY FOR THE CLIPPERS
TEAM.
THE ONLY REASON THEY ARE WINNING
ANY GAMES IS BECAUSE OF PAUL
GEORGE.
PHOTOCOPY THAT IS NOT VALUABLE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IS.
WE WILL SEE.
YOU HAVE TO ROLL WITH STEPH AND
THE WAY THAT HE IS PLAYING
BASKETBALL.
HE IS DEFINITELY THE FRONTRUNNER
FOR SURE.
>> IF IT AIN'T BROKE DON'T FIX
IT.
WE ARE STILL BEFORE CHRISTMAS.
IT IS EARLY.
IT IS STILL EARLY IN THIS NBA
SEASON.
TAKE STEPH.
I AM BACK INTO THE COMMENTS
GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
HERE WE GO.
GOAT GARDEN SAID THEY NEED
KAWHI.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
AK47 BIG BLUE KERR IS GOING TO
WIN.
IF HE SLOWS DOWN THE ONLY PERSON
TO CATCH UP WOULD BE GIANNIS.
GIANNIS COMING OUT OF THE WOOD
WORKS.
MAYBE.
I LIKE K.D. TOO.
I THINK K.D. IS THE BEST PLAYER
IN THE NBA RIGHT NOW.
LIV, OUR TIME HAS COME TO AN
END.
IT IS TIME TO SIGN OUT.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR TAPPING INTO
THE GROUP CHAT PRESENTED BY
FANDUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
GET IN THE COMMENTS.
DROP YOUR BEST GUESS FOR WHEN
STEPH WILL BREAK THE RECORD.
WE ARE GIVING AWAY AN IPHONE 13
TO SOMEBODY IN THE COMMENTS.
DROP THAT TIME.
DRAYMOND SHOULD WIN DEFENSIVE
PLAYER OF THE YEAR.
WE KNOW THAT.
GET ON FANDUEL TO TELL OUR
SPECIAL STEPH ODDS BOOST, THE B
BALL BING BONG AND BR BETTING
SAME GAME PARLAY.
MY PRODUCER WROTE THAT.
GET ON THE BING BING PARLAY.
TUNE IN TO THE NBA PREGAME SHOW
TONIGHT TO SEE CHUCK PICKING HIS
FAVORITE LEG OF OUR PARLAY.
WE WILL BE BACK NEXT WEEK LIV.
IF YOU WON A HOODIE TODAY WE
WILL DM YOU.
I AM GREG IVORY.
WE ARE LEAVING THE GROUP CHAT.
PEACE.
♪ ♪